when you become comfortable with
uncertainty this is a great concept
comfortable with uncertainty infinite
possibilities open up in your life
why because not being comfortable with
uncertainty turns to worry
and that turns to fear react to
uncertainty with
increased aliveness alertness and
creativity and create your own
wonderful possibilities
that's it that's one of the most
uplifting things i said i read
and anything that eckhart tolle has
written at least that i read
maybe he has other stuff out there but i
i look at that and going
that to me sounds like you know it's
just it's full of
everything wonderful uh going back to
patients being the measurement
of the uh well i actually didn't cover
that yet in which we have
you know we said patience is a great
measure of our spiritual development
but casey goes on to indicate that
patience is the measurement
of our understanding of a manifested
idea
go back to that krishnamurti thing where
he said
that he doesn't mind what happens to him
why because he has so much faith that
everything's working to good
that it's going now you can do that
through faith but i think through great
patience you actually intuitively begin
to understand
that when i broke my hip it's so i can
win the lottery
i mean it literally will get that clear
to us with a greater clarity that
we have using our intuition so that's
why the uh
edgar casey readings say that patience
is the best measurement of our soul
development because it opens us up to
that
so you can
you know when you get to that point this
is one that
it draws a lot of concern from people
but casey said that jesus
actually laughed and joked on his way to
mount calvary
and he's sitting there carrying that
cross up the road
to mount calvary he was literally joking
and laughing
with the crowd out there and there were
two reasons for it as far as what casey
brought up he said first of all
when he had that attitude of what he was
going through how do you think the right
he wasn't doing it to upset the roman
soldiers he was doing it to let them
know
you can do all of this to me and i am
still in control of who i am and how i
feel
the other one was to be the perfect role
model to everyone else
letting them know that if you find
yourself in a position like this
you too if you have the christ
consciousness will be able to be in
total control of how you think and feel
no matter how bad it gets out there all
right so
what a great role model to be able to
talk about
how he was able to show that to us